you know when i when i heard that i got
the call that my agent called me and he
told me what was going on
um
you know it definitely hurt me i hold
myself at a high level
you know the rams don't they don't they
don't take calls on aaron donald
the patriots don't take calls on tom
brady you know i mean that's where i
hold myself in that regard so
regardless of
i understand that you have a job to do
that's the way i took it
that's jamal adams jet safety meeting
with reporters on wednesday one day
after he was
shopped or not shopped whatever the case
may be because his position on tuesday
was i'm upset that you were shopping me
the team's explanation through gm jet uh
joe douglas was well we weren't shopping
you people were calling us and making
offers and we were listening so adam's
response is well
the patriots don't listen when people
call about tom brady the rams don't
listen when people call about aaron
donald and chris look i'll do respect to
jamal adams
he's not tom brady he's not aaron donald
no he's not in that that that narrow
narrow slice of untradable player if
someone's going to offer a first-round
pick plus for jamal adams the jets are
gonna listen yeah i you know again you
know i like jamal adams he plays with
passion he's a phenomenal football
player um
yeah he's putting himself in a rarefied
air right now where he doesn't you know
the
whoa whoa horsey whoa
like that's crazy town okay come on now
right now aaron donald is like gonna go
down in history is like maybe the
greatest defensive tackle we've ever
seen in the nfl in the history of the
sport he's gonna go down as one of the
all-time greats when there's a team of
like oh the all 150-year team of the nfl
aaron donald and tom brady are going to
be on it okay so different stratosphere
and if it wasn't for mr kraft i think
that new england would take calls if you
offered something crazy you know maybe
not now but at some point all right and
then this is also tom brady where we're
talking about three super bowls and all
those things are you know six super
bowls excuse me and you know of course
won three of them very early in his
career
aaron donald
again i think there was they took calls
when they weren't sure what they were
going to do with their contract there
there was calls taken there when people
called hey maybe you guys aren't going
to get this done you willing to trade
them anything like that well i think
there was plenty of teams that called
the los angeles rams and they listened
did they want to give them away no just
like jamal adams and the jets they
didn't want to give him away either so
it's the same thing and i'm with you
just got to pump the brakes there on
that you know don't tell me you're going
to be professional and everything like
that and then make comments like that
that are not really that professional
you know come on we just you know just
at some point everybody's just got to be
quiet get off of social media and play
football and stop worrying about making
statements all the time
well look and and i firmly believe that
to be a successful professional athlete
you have to be confident to the point of
delusional but you can't be delusional
there's a line there that you have to
respect you have to have confidence in
your abilities but you can't be popping
off with comments like that that that
will open the door for criticism that
will be accurate criticism jamal adams
also refused to meet with joe douglas
the gm of the jets on wednesday so there
you go again clear the air
yeah and i'm gonna continue to act like
a professional but not so you know i
just i you lose me you start to lose me
after you bs me a few too many times
sorry
and what he's done he's validated the
fact that they were willing to consider
trading and because we're getting a
glimpse of what the jets deal with all
the time peter king and i argued about
this on his podcast earlier this week my
position was and still is the jets know
this guy better than anyone they deal
with him every day they see him in the
meeting room they see him on the
practice field they see him on the bus
on the plane they're around him all the
time he's a temperamental guy last year
it seemed like every other week coach
todd bowles had to try to reign him in
because he said something in a press
conference or a radio interview that
created problems because it seemed like
he was calling people out and and this
year he's he's improved in that regard
but but this is a feisty temperamental
player and at some point you have to ask
is he more trouble than he's worth
especially if somebody's going to give
us a first round pick plus for him right
yeah and right now i don't think he's
worth more trouble than he's worth
because he is in the conversation for
one of the best safeties in football and
i get that but you know it's just we're
seeing some warning signs where we just
want to go you know do do do please stop
please stop like you're going you know
you're digging yourself into a hole and
you're gonna lose again like we're
talking about with baker mayfield the
battle of public perception here in new
york you know there's already new
yorkers that think oh he's a knucklehead
now he's already been put in that
category and that's where i just want to
tell a young guy who i have a lot of
respect for his dad played with my
father and the new york giants and this
guy is a baller and i've been around him
i just don't want him to go into the
spouting off category every time
something little thing happens and then
he gets perceived to be a pain in the
butt on a football team or a
hard-to-handle guy in the locker room
that's where i just want to talk to
jamal adams and say that but
let me say this though too just like
with baker mayfield this is part of what
makes him who he is it is makes him a
great player i know you have to be
willing to take the bad with the good
and my point is this if somebody's going
to offer you
a first round pick plus more stuff
you're going to at least evaluate
life without jamal adams which is what
the jets did but they decided to keep
him at least for now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports